how does the writer know what they were
good at oh good question
I think a lot of that's gonna come from
your own confidence a lot of that is
gonna come from
just like within just knowing like this
is a natural skill for me this is a
natural area for me but I do think it
takes some time to get there which is
why when writers work with me out
actually those kinds of questions like
are you writing what you'd like to write
or are you writing what you like to
watch are you writing characters that
you know very well or are you writing
characters that you observe which is
fine but make sure that if there are
people that you just observe that you
then try to get in there so you really
know why they do the things that they do
you know and I think a lot of the times
we write what we think is on trend we
write what we think people are going to
buy and by doing that you're not
necessarily finding your niche though
you might be finding I don't like this
but the question is are you then gonna
be honest with yourself and say I don't
like writing this so then you're stop
writing that and start writing what you
do like so I think it takes some work
but I also think it just takes some
honesty like within like just just like
it would for anyone who's working any
job there are people who are on their
job right now and they know I don't like
this or they know I have a different
skillset and I do like my job and I had
this skill set they can give me this
promotion but nobody else can see it
like people you know just kind of know
just like we said about that athlete
thing just kind of know that it's gonna
be football or basketball or golf or
whatever even though when you're a young
kid your parents might you know put you
in all five of them and eventually you
just narrow it down and say well this is
the one I like so the same thing is true
for writers I mean I think you have to
go with your first good write because
most people start writing because they
had an idea they usually aren't people
who just start writing because they're
in a writing class most people are I
have this idea so they start writing so
great write it get it out see if your
next ideas in that same wheelhouse and
then what about your next one and if
they're all kind of in that same place
then you start to realize either this is
what I like or this is what I'm good at
but we also know just as again as people
a lot of us do a lot of us are great at
things that we don't like to do you know
you hear people say all the time like
this is what I'm great at but I want to
do that
like for example I'm a great teacher I
do not want to be a teacher
so the kind of teaching that I do is by
teaching adults in online screenwriting
courses or doing workshops so I'm still
a teacher as a script consultant I am a
teacher but I am NOT the what what
people consider a teacher I don't get up
every morning and have to be in a
classroom full of little people all day
I don't want to do it I've been fighting
it my whole life just the other day my
mother said to me well you know since
you work from home you should probably
go ahead and get your teaching
certification I don't want to be a
teacher you know but it's just a natural
you know a natural skill that I have to
be a teacher so the same thing is true
for a writer you just have to be honest
with yourself about this is my skill set
but is this what I like doing and figure
out if you can find like what that
middle ground is something that you're
skilled at and you actually like and
some people are group people and others
are excellent one-on-one I think yes and
that's gonna matter because if you're
not a group person then you don't want
to write TV and so I have people say all
the time like I wouldn't be a TV writer
and it's like but you don't take good
notes you don't like to be around people
okay you know and you think that this
process is all about you you can't
possibly want to write TV TV most TV
shows it's changed a little bit because
now we have streamers now we have blah
blah blah so things happen all kinds of
different ways but most TV shows have a
writers room that you're gonna be stuck
in for weeks for you know 10 12 hours a
day sometimes with you and then
discussing discussing discussing
discussing you don't want to be around
people you might not want to write TV
the same is true for if you don't want
to move to Los Angeles you probably
don't want to write TV right because
most TV writers rooms are in Los Angeles
sure there are a couple literally a
couple in Atlanta maybe a couple in New
York but 90 something percent of the
writers rooms are here in Los Angeles
you don't have to live in office Angeles
to be a feature writer it's probably
best that you do at least at the
beginning of your career so you can meet
the people you need to meet because here
in LA in LA because film is the industry
you might run into someone
you know I mean like these people are
everywhere and if you're gonna have a
meeting they're gonna call you in a lot
of times they're not gonna do their
first type meetings over the phone it's
just not gonna happen that way then once
you come in they want to see you and
depending upon what you do for a living
you can't afford to fly and get a hotel
every single time you take a meeting
right so still being in LA it's probably
a good thing to do if you're a writer
because you want to be able to just be
in the mix meet the people get to know
the people and be able to see them face
to face but other than that after you've
established yourself as a feature writer
you can live wherever you want because
you can submit via email you know what I
mean you don't have to be here but for
TV writers most of the rooms are here so
that's something that people should take
into consideration when they're deciding
they want to be a writer you got to ask
yourself those questions too am i a team
player or do I want to do this thing
solo
do I want to live in Los Angeles or do I
want to live in Connecticut like where
do you want to be how many screenwriters
have you come across who only have one
screenplay completed most of them I
would say the majority of them only have
one screenplay completed and that's okay
especially if they're in the beginning
then they're still trying to figure out
what it is they want to do or if this is
really what they want to do or if again
I just have an idea and I want to get my
baby made then I'd only expect them to
have more screenplays because it's not
about them becoming professional writers
it's about them getting their baby made
for those who I know wants to be
professional writers then we start to
have those conversations about okay when
it's time for you to meet an agent or a
manager or whoever whomever they're
gonna say what else do you have so you
got to have something else and again
thinking about branding yourself you
want to have something else within your
voice see we get it a little bit twisted
because we start to think well I want to
show them how diverse I am right so I'm
gonna have one of these and one of these
and one of these in one of these it
actually does the opposite for writers
if they don't already know you if you're
brand new it that's the opposite they
want to be able to read three of your
scripts and understand you're a voice
they want to be able to read three of
your scripts and understand these are
the characters you write well this is
the world you know well right so if you
write big-city things then what's in
your writing sample should be big city
things if you write small town things
then all of your writing samples should
be small town things
and it doesn't mean that you can't write
big-city things but you're just again
trying to say but this is my voice this
is what I write understand my brand so
it's not a negative thing if you only
have one screenplays just the question
is what do you want to do if you want to
be a professional writer then you got to
go write more because writers have to
write and if the people that you work
with as a script consultant or even just
email you to test the waters how many of
them have never let anyone else see that
one screenplay hmm I would say I think
it's a little hard now that it's we're
it's 2019 and there are like script
coverage services all over the internet
so I don't meet very many people who
haven't let somebody else read it even
if they're not even if they aren't
professionals but I think I'm usually
the first like professional person that
they've had Rita you know maybe mom read
it or sister read it or cousin already
you know but I think I'm usually like
one of the one of the first professional
people and I think that's also because
even though all of those resources are
out there a lot of people never utilize
the resources like they haven't really
googled people don't even know and I'm
not saying that they should but they
don't even know that a script consultant
exists so they're not thinking let me go
google script consultant you know some
of them are thinking the only way I'm
gonna learn how to write a screenplay if
I go to film school they're not thinking
there are online classes there are
one-day workshops there are three day
workshops people aren't really thinking
that so they're not even looking forward
you know they may the most they may do
is like go google some books and go to
the library and get the books or go buy
the books or amazon the books or
whatever but for the most part by the
time they get to me I'm like the first
professional opinion they're getting and
they usually have found me on social
media by accident I'm not even looking
for me you know I think that's how I
found you
ya know that's the great thing about you
know 2020 is that people can just
randomly find you so I think they're
usually like oh my god you're the you're
what I've been needing this whole time I
just didn't know that you existed you
know and that's the hard part about
being an entrepreneur is figuring out
you know how you're gonna market
yourself so people know that you exist
because it's like once people know me
they're like I need you and they usually
you usually utilize me and almost all of
them come back like all of my my
I usually return clients and that's if
they're writing quickly enough because
as we know somebody may write something
this year and they might not write
another thing for you know two more
years that happens with some people but
for those of those of my clients who are
actually trying to become professional
writers and they're writing off and they
always come back with whatever their
next project is and it becomes like a
team effort you know like like I'm a
part of the team if I'm gonna write
something Shannon's gonna read it she's
gonna give me some notes and she's gonna
be real with me always tell people if
you don't want you know my honest
opinion again not my subjective opinion
cuz that's not what it's about this is
not about me saying this is good or bad
but if you don't want me to let you know
that some of the choices you're making
aren't being executed the way that you
think they're being executed then I'm
not the person for you you know but if
you want me to just give it to you
straight I'll give it to you straight
and at the end of the day you can always
not listen that's the best part about it
you don't have to take the note because
it's your work and you can decide to do
with it what you please do you think
most people are fine with that in terms
of they actually want you yeah to give
me I think I've only had I've had maybe
two or three people give push back and
I'm all wait I'm fine with it
because I'm not here to prove to you
that my feedback is correct this is
still art you can decide to do whatever
you know and so a lot of my feedback is
usually in questions because I don't
want to tell you what to think I want to
tell you what I think you're saying and
see if we're on the same page so I will
usually ask a whole lot of questions I
then sometimes get people who respond
back answering the questions it's like
that's not what I need you to do I'm
asking them because it's not clear on
your page so you need to go put that on
the page just like you can't stand
outside all of the theatres and answer
everybody's questions I'm not asking you
to answer my questions here I'm saying
if I'm asking that means it's not there
if I'm asking whatever it is you're
trying to make happening isn't happening
sometimes that's okay sometimes that's
what you're doing on purpose fine I
don't need the answer you don't have to
prove anything to me I then will have
other people push back simply because
they got a different set of feedback
from somebody else and that's fine I'll
always say to them great if you get
another set of feedback and that person
says what
I said or that person said with the
other set the other person said then now
you know which direction are going to
because if you hear it more than once
then it's probably a problem right so
yeah I've had a couple of people push
back simply because they said well the
problem that you see is not a problem
and I say you know that's fine
my only feedback to that is if it wasn't
a problem we wouldn't be having this
conversation right like you sent it to
me because it's not working for you I've
given you the reasons why it's not
working and you say well that's not why
it's not working well that's fine you
don't have to take the notes I wish you
best you know with your with your
project and hopefully it'll work out for
you I don't ever want someone's project
to not work just because I gave the note
and they didn't want to take it you know
what I mean like that's again what makes
it art so you don't have to take the
note but I think again going back to
well this is my baby where it's personal
I've been writing like I had one woman
respond I've been writing for this many
years and I've baba blah blah blah
that's great
these are the problems that I see
hopefully it works out for you there's
not very much you know much else I can I
can say to it but it's not it doesn't
become like a a war between whose
feedback is correct or isn't it like I'm
not gonna take it personally if you
don't take one note you know I'm going
to do my job to the best of my ability
as professional as I can professionally
as I can and you can take it or you can
leave it and that's okay
you